MALE SPEAKER: Happy Halloween.
Welcome to Talks at
Google in Cambridge, Mass.
It's great to see
such a big crowd.
I think we all know
why we're here,
because this office is such a
huge supporter of neuroscience.
I'm sure I am not
the only person who
subscribes to Alerts
on Google Scholar.
Tim Verstynen, faculty
at Carnegie Mellon today.
This is just a small
sample of his papers.
His co-author, Bradley Voytek
of UC San Diego, similarly.
These are giants in the field.
They're also pioneers in the
field of zombie research.
And there's not a
lot more to say.
I know their parents are
exceptionally proud of them.
I know we're eager
to hear what Tim
has to say about developments
in this emerging field
that he is helping
to blaze a path in.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming the author of
this seminal and groundbreaking
book, "Do Zombies
Dream of Undead Sheep?
A Neuroscientific View of the
Zombie Brain," Tim Verstynen.
TIM VERSTYNEN: Thank you, and
Happy Halloween, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
Before I get into
it, I just would
like to point out that my
collaborator, Bradley Voytek,
and I have kind of
teamed up on this.
And what you're going
to see is a hobby
that's gone out of hand.
It's just-- we are
both zombie geeks,
and how this started was
that in graduate school
we were both in the same
program, and in our off hours
we liked to just geek out
and watch zombie movies.
And being nerds,
we decided, well,
what would happen
with the zombie brain?
And it all went
downhill from there.
So you're about to see
the aftermath of that.
But before I really get into
the nitty gritty details, just
a disclaimer, I'm going to be
showing clips from some zombie
movies, primarily "Night
of the Living Dead,"
because it's the best
zombie movie ever.
So it's going to be a little
bit of 1960s-style gore,
and some spoilers.
So just be warned.
All right.
So I get asked this question
a lot by my colleagues
in neuroscience.
Why zombie neuroscience?
Why are we doing this silly
endeavor on our off hours
instead of writing another Grant
Well, Brad and I are both big
science outreach advocates.
And one of the things
we're interested in
is trying to get general
audiences more engaged
with basic science information.
By and large, the way
the broader public
gets science is filtered through
types of media sources that
try to spin it and make big
mountains of small molehills.
And often it gets distorted.
So I think we need to get the
general public more engaged
in the real core
scientific literature.
So we've thought about
possibilities of doing this.
One, we thought about using
internet memes as our figures
to illustrate our findings.
So, you know, use your LOL cat
to display heavy in networks.
That didn't go over so well.
We pondered accidentally
releasing sex tapes
during our lectures to get a
broader audience coming in.
Our lawyers suggested
that we don't do that.
And we thought well, maybe
we could attract more readers
to our journal
articles if we just
added a Kardashian
to the author list.
Again, apparently, you
need their permission
in order to put them
on the author list.
So this didn't work.
And each one of these approaches
has the following structure.
What we're doing is we're
trying to take aspects
of popular culture and
inject it into science,
and kind of pull people
into the basic science.
And it's kind of hard to do.
So I think what we need to
do is, instead, flip this,
and say bring science
into popular culture.
How can we start bringing
real scientific principles
into popular culture in
order to educate the broader
public on scientific issues?
And so this was
our first attempt
at this kind of leveraging
of science information
into popular culture.
And so, of course, us
being zombie nerds,
well, we're going to take
a look at zombies first.
They're actually
a perfect example
for exploring neuroscientific
ideas in this broader context.
So that's why
zombie neuroscience.
So for the next about half
an hour or so, bear with me.
We're going to be
suspending our disbelief
and pretending that outside,
around Kendall Square,
the undead are walking around.
In fact, on a Halloween
like today, there probably
are undead walking
around Kendall Square.
So welcome to The Science
of Surviving the Zombie
Apocalypse, more importantly
the neuroscience of it.
So as a scientist, and as a
neuroscientist in particular,
when I see a zombie
like this woman here,
I see an undead
creature, yes, but I also
see a spectrum of very
particular types of behaviors
that you see repeated
again and again
and again in "The Walking Dead."
You see things like
hyperaggression,
memory deficits,
attention problems.
You'll see language destruction,
reduced impulse control,
movement disorders, and even
visual recognition impairments.
And these are seen across
almost every genre of the zombie
movie.
So as a neuroscientist,
this tells us
something very interesting.
This gives us some
pretty key insights
into what's happened to
this individual's brain
as she's gone from being
a high school cheerleader
into being a ravenous zombie.
So using this collective
set of behaviors
that have changed
in the zombie, we
were able to
actually reconstruct
a model of what the
zombie brain looks like.
Let me show you our model here.
So on the left, right here, is
a normal, neurologically healthy
human individual.
There's lots of tissue packed
into a really small space,
so it's very wrinkly.
And it's a very robust,
healthy-looking structure.
On the right is
the zombie brain.
And what you see is
lots of big gaps,
lots of space that's unused.
In fact, this
little guy back here
is completely gone
in the zombie brain.
We're going to get to
that a little bit later.
So this shows atrophy
in the zombie brain.
And this atrophy that
you're seeing isn't random.
Each one of the areas that's
decayed away in the zombie
brain reflects a very
particular symptom
that we see in zombieism.
So the goal of "Do Zombies
Dream of Undead Sheep?"
is to take apart the
behavior of zombies
and link it back up to each one
of these brain regions that's
been atrophied and destroyed
in the zombie brain.
So that's what we're
going to do today,
and just looking at a
few of these symptoms.
Now before we do,
we're scientists.
We like to take what seems
like supernatural phenomenon
and make it dry and boring
and clinically defined.
So we're going to
define zombieism
not as zombies, but as
a clinical disorder.
And so we're going to call
it Consciousness Deficit
Hypoactivity
Disorder, CDHD, which
is defined as the loss of
rational, voluntary, and
conscious behavior
that's been replaced
by delusional
impulsive aggression,
stimulus-driven attention, and
the inability to coordinate
motor or linguistic behaviors.
There.
We've stripped away
all the really weird,
supernatural stuff and made
it a nice, clean, studyable
phenomenon.
Also, with a cool
name like CDHD,
maybe we can get a
pharmaceutical company
to fund our research.
All right.
So from now we're going to
be calling zombieism CDHD.
And we're going
to try to explore
the neural underpinnings
of CDHD by going
through a set of symptoms
that we see with the disorder.
So the first symptom, or the
first behavioral characteristic
that people notice when
they encounter the undead,
is their hyperaggression.
Let's see an example
of this behavior.
This is Karen.
Karen's just recently
turned to the undead.
And here she's, I believe,
eating the arm of her father.
And let's see what happens when
Karen runs into her mother.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Karen?
Karen?
Karen.
What, baby?
Baby!
TIM VERSTYNEN:
Because you always
gotta get the garden shears.
[SCREAMING]
[END PLAYBACK]
TIM VERSTYNEN: We'll save
you the blood and gore there,
but I think it's pretty
safe to say that Karen's
pretty angry with
her mother, right?
Now most normal kids who are
not angry with their parents
don't grab a garden shear
and start stabbing them.
So this type of
aggression is interesting
because it's very reflective of
a well-described type of anger
known as reactive-impulsive
regression.
This is a subtype
of aggression--
and this is a quote from an
actual scientific paper--
"a subtype of aggression
that can result
in sudden, heightened, enduring,
or inappropriate aggressive
responses."
So this is the stimulus-driven
type of aggression
that you'll see when you engage
the body's fight or flight
responses.
And it's very different
than the type of aggression
you see in, say, something
like a school shooting, which
is a very calculated, decisive,
cool type of aggression.
And we know a lot about
the neural underpinnings
of this reactive-impulsive
aggression.
We sometimes call this
road rage aggression.
So this type of
aggressive behavior
is well-characterized
in many animal models.
So we've laid out a lot of
the neural circuits that
drive this type of response.
So let's take a look at
those neural circuits.
The control of
aggression, normally,
in hopefully everyone
in this room,
is regulated by
areas in the front
of the brain in the
prefrontal cortex,
usually around what's known
as the orbitofrontal cortex
or complex.
And this is a set of
higher-level brain areas
that regulate a lot
of different things.
But one of the things
they do is they
regulate control of
subcortical networks, networks
that are buried
deep in the brain.
And in particular, one
area, known as the amygdala,
receives extensive input from
this orbitofrontal complex.
And what this does is
it acts as a cooling
mechanism for amygdala function.
So the orbitofrontal cortex
is doing the, sshhh, it's OK.
It's OK.
And the amygdala
is hypersensitive
to potential threats
in the environment.
It's always looking
for a threat.
So if we wanted to couch this
in Freudian terms-- and please,
I hope my department
chair doesn't
hear me talking about Freud
in this talk-- you can think
of the amygdala as being
the id and orbitofrontal
cortex as being the superego.
It's trying to keep this
reactive, primal, instinctive
fight or flight response intact.
So the amygdala
controls aggression
through a very particular set
of interactions between areas
known as the hypothalamus
and the thalamus,
which in turn send
excitatory projections
to an area of the brain known
as the periaqueductal gray.
This is buried deep,
deep in the brain.
And the periaqueductal
gray stimulates
your arousal mechanisms, so
it's what gets you ramped up,
and in this case, aggressive.
So normally the
prefrontal cortex
is saying, calm
down, don't react.
That guy cut you off in traffic.
Don't throw a brick
through his window.
But if you remove the
orbitofrontal cortex
from the equation, what
happens is these subcortical
fight or flight
responses are unchecked.
So you get an unconstrained
amygdala response,
which, through this
network of other areas,
increases sensitivity
to reactive behaviors.
And what you get if you wipe
out those prefrontal control
mechanisms is you get a
unconstrained, impulsive rage.
You get more appetite
dysregulation, chronic stress
responses.
You'll even get
appetite dysregulation.
So these are all behaviors that
you see in animals with damage
to the orbitofrontal areas.
And you also see it in zombies.
So I think it's a
pretty good guess
that that's what we're
seeing, at least in this case,
with zombies.
So if you look at the human
brain and the zombie brain side
by side, the
orbitofrontal areas that
tend to control this
type of reactive response
rest right up here.
This is the front side of the
brain, looking at the front,
and this is an underview
of the brain here.
If we look at the
zombie brain, we
see an atrophy of these
prefrontal networks.
So that control
region has gone away.
But that's not all.
We don't just see extensive
damage to the zombie brain.
We actually see some
plasticity as well.
So if we look at those
subcortical areas,
like the amygdala and
the thalamus-- so this
is a slice through the brain
right about here on the left,
showing the may amygdala in
red, and this guy on the right,
this is a slice of the brain
this way showing the thalamus.
And if you look at the volume
of these two subcortical areas,
the humans are displayed
in gray and zombies
are displayed in orange.
And we see, actually, these
areas should be bigger.
These areas are more enlarged
in the zombie or CDHD subtypes
than what you see in humans.
So they're unconstrained.
They're using more resources and
they're building more neurons,
so they're becoming
more sensitive.
So this explains
a little bit how
you have this reactive
aggression in the zombie brain.
So let's look at another
symptom of the zombie epidemic,
or the CDHD epidemic.
Let's look at
visual recognition.
I'm going to show you two scenes
of the same two individuals.
The first is the scene before
this gentleman here, Johnny,
has turned.
And this is his sister Barbara.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So really be scared here.
-Johnny.
-You're still afraid.
-Stop it, now.
I mean it.
-They're coming to
get you, Barbara.
-Stop it.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
So it's very obvious he knows
who this person is, right?
Now let's look at Johnny
after he's become a zombie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SCREAMING]
-No!
No, get out!
No!
No, Johnny, no!
No, no!
No!
[END PLAYBACK]
So notice he doesn't have
that glint of recognition
in his eye.
He doesn't see his sister.
He just sees a human that
he can devour, right?
He doesn't recognize her at all.
This seems to be a
common phenomenon
throughout the
zombie genre, right?
You see, many times, two
high school sweethearts.
One gets bitten and
turns into a zombie.
As soon as they
turn into the zombie
they start to eat the
cheek of their loved one
because they no
longer recognize them.
They just react as if this
is just some random person
they can devour.
And this type of visual
recognition problem
resembles a well-described
psychiatric disorder
known as Capgras Delusion.
Capgras Delusion
is the false belief
that the people you know well
have been replaced by impostors
and are typically
seen as a threat.
This is kind of the "Invasion
of the Body Snatchers"
psychiatric disorder.
Very real disorder.
So, you know, you
wake up one morning,
and suddenly that's not your
wife laying next to you.
That's some alien that's
inhabited your wife's body.
She might look, sound,
talk like my wife,
but she's not really my wife.
This isn't always bad.
There was a case
reported of a woman who
was in a miserable
marriage for years.
She, I think, had a stroke,
developed Capgras Delusion,
and was convinced that
her husband was replaced
by Casanova and
that she was having
an illicit affair
with this Casanova
that was in her husband's body.
And then her love life
actually improved.
So it's not always bad.
But Capgras Delusion is
a psychiatric problem,
which means it's
characterized at this kind
of behavioral level.
But we don't really know the
neural underpinnings of it.
But the phenomenon
is very similar
to a well-described
neurological phenomenon
known as prosopagnosia.
Prosopagnosia is the inability
to link a person's identity
to the visual image
of their face.
So in the classic scenario,
somebody with prosopagnosia,
you stand them in front
of a mirror and say, who's
looking back at you?
And they won't be able
to tell you who they are.
They'll just say, I see a face.
I see that person.
They've got a beard.
But I don't know who they are.
Or another famous example
is an experimenter
will be showing a set
of faces on the screen.
The experimenter's face
will come on the screen.
The experimenter's
right here, and the guy
asks, who are you
seeing on the screen?
And the patient will reply,
I don't know, somebody.
So this type of
disorder has been
described in the neurological
literature for about 100 years
or so now.
And it's linked to
disorders or damage
to a particular network of areas
in the brain known as the face
network.
OK.
So the face network,
particularly an area
known as the fusiform face
area, are a well-described set
of brain areas that
are sensitive to seeing
faces more than
any other object.
In fact, the face area
was first described at MIT
by Nancy Kanwisher
about 20 years ago.
So the way the face
network is characterized
is, let's say I put
you in an MRI scanner
and look at the functional
activation of your brain
when I show you pictures.
So I show you a picture
of this dude here,
and then I show you
pictures of houses or cars.
And I say, which areas are
more active to this face
than to these cars?
Well, what you
would see is a set
of regions in the
back of the head
on the underside
of the neocortex.
So each one of these blobs
here shows a separate region
that's more responsive to
this face than anything else.
This is sometimes known
as the core face network.
And what these are is a set of
well-connected brain regions
that basically deconstruct
the visual image of the face,
reassemble it, and link it
categorically to an individual.
So it's a stream of information
starting in the back, where
the primary visual cortex is,
that just sees spatial features
and keeps moving forward to
higher-level areas of the brain
until it's linked up to a face.
So damage to any
part of this network
can lead to prosopagnosia.
And I'm going to show you
an interesting example
of temporarily
induced prosopagnosia.
What we're going
to see is a patient
who's about ready to
undergo neurosurgery.
He's got a tumor
in the underside
of his brain near that
core face network.
And surgeons want
to resect the tumor,
but they don't want to
make him prosopagnosic.
So what they did is they
implanted stimulators
on the underside of his brain.
And what they're
going to do is they're
going to stimulate
different parts and see
where does his face
perception get disrupted?
And that way they
can map out where
those face-selective areas
are and the neurosurgeon
can kind of work around them.
So you're going to
see two trials here.
In one trial, the
experimenter isn't
going to deliver any
stimulation at all.
In the second trial,
they're actually
going to deliver simulation.
So this took place in
Stanford, and this patient
has no neuroscience or
psychology background
whatsoever.
So he doesn't know
what's going on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And tell me what happens
when I do this, all right?
-OK.
-One, two, three.
-Nothing.
-Nothing?
I'm going to do
it one more time.
Look at my face.
One, two, three.
-You just turned
into somebody else.
Your face metamorphosed.
Your nose got saggy,
went to the left.
You almost looked like
somebody I'd seen before,
but somebody different.
That was a trip.
[END PLAYBACK]
I love that last line.
So just a brief stimulation
of these face areas--
in this particular case it
was the fusiform face area--
cause this disruption of
the perception of the face.
And so as the clip goes
on-- I don't have time
to show you the entire
clip-- the experimenter keeps
turning down the voltage and
keeps turning down the current.
And eventually he says,
your face didn't change.
I just didn't know you were you.
So the disconnect between
seeing the face and the identity
of the experimenter-- he was
looking at the experimenter,
he knew who this person
was-- just got disconnected.
So this is a great example
of a transiently induced
prosopagnosia.
The whole image of the
face just got torn apart.
So the face network is part
of a larger visual network
in the brain known as the
ventral visual stream.
And so this is the ventral
visual stream in one
of our zombie
experimental subjects.
So this is the primary
visual cortex here.
And the information that flows
on the underside of the brain,
mostly along the
temporal lobe-- and this
is the undercurrent
here-- is part
of the ventral visual stream.
So this is the fusiform face
area I talked about earlier.
This is known classically
is the "what" pathway.
It's the pathway
in your brain that
tries to assemble
object knowledge
and recognize
objects in the world.
So if we look at this
what pathway in a human--
if we did a slice right
through the brain,
this would be like a sagittal
slice right through here--
this is the main
core of the what
pathway on the left
and right side.
In the zombie brain,
the what pathway
would be extensively damaged.
So they would have impaired face
knowledge, object knowledge.
And this is actually
where the fusiform face
area sits in the
right hemisphere.
So we're going to say
that not only are zombies
losing the prefrontal
control of their aggression.
They've also lost the
ability to recognize
faces and other objects,
with few exceptions.
OK.
Another classic
deficit we see in CDHD
all the time is language.
Zombies don't talk.
In fact, I'm going to show
you an example of the most
fluent zombie we know of,
if you ignore that movie
"Warm Bodies."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Brains.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
That's Tarman.
Tarman is the individual who
single-handedly linked brains
to zombies.
Up until Tarman, brains
and zombies weren't linked.
Zombies would eat
any part of the body.
They'd go for the liver before
they'd go for the brain.
But Tarman had a particular
taste for brains.
And so he was the one who was
always going after brains.
But I want you to
notice something.
Here he was asking this teenager
if he could eat her brains.
But he didn't say,
can you come over
here so that I can
eat your brains?
Or, please come by because your
gray matter looks delicious.
No, he just said, brains, right?
You got the idea, but it
was a single-word sentence.
That type of
phenomenon, if we see it
in clinical
neurological patients,
is known as telegraphia.
So the idea being that patients
who are having difficulty
getting words out will resort
to just the most critical parts
of the sentence, the most
critical semantic parts
of the sentence, and take
away all the other fluency.
And the name comes
from the old telegraph,
for long-distance communication
a hundred and some years ago.
In that case you paid
by the character, right?
So you had to make your notes
short, sweet, and to the point.
The same is true
with these patients.
They have trouble
getting out words.
So the whole idea
is just to get out
the key most important
parts of the sentence.
Now telegraphia is a
symptom that you've
seen in a larger class of
disorders known as aphasias.
And aphasias are a broad
term that reflect, really,
any language deficit, but
there's many subtypes.
For example, there's
the inability
to produce language,
which is classically
known as Broca's Aphasia,
or difficulty comprehending
language, which is classically
known as Wernicke's Aphasia.
And each one of these two areas
has different cortical sources
but that play a larger
part in the language
networks of the brain.
So this is Tarman here,
holding his favorite dish,
so this is a human
brain right here.
We're looking on the left side.
So Broca's area is
right up here in front.
And this is the area
that, if you damage it,
gets you Broca's Aphasia.
It's tightly linked up
to the motor cortex,
and it's single-handedly linked
to the language production
end of things.
So it's what forms
your mouth movements
and your gestural patterns
to producing language.
In the back, right
in the temporal lobe,
or right by the temporal
lobe and the parietal
where they meet, you
see Wernicke's Area,
which is a region that's linked
to language comprehension.
So if you damage Wernicke's
Area, you can get words out.
They're just discombobulated.
They're not well-structured.
You also have difficulty
understanding people.
And these two areas
are connected together
by a very large bundle of
white matter pathways known
as the Arcuate Fasciculus.
These are big superhighways
of the brain that
connect Wernicke's
and Broca's area.
And you think about it as
language, what you're doing
is you're constructing the idea
and semantics of what you're
saying, you're shipping all that
information out to the output
area of the language
circuit and saying,
ship out this information
to the rest of the world.
So information typically
flows from Wernicke's over
to Broca's.
And damage to any
one of these areas
will impair language function.
So if we look at this circuit
in the human and zombie brain--
this is the human on the left--
Broca's would be right about up
here and Wernicke's
right about back here--
if you look in the zombie
brain, we see extensive atrophy
in both ends of the circuit.
So basically this tells us,
don't try talking to a zombie.
They're not going
to understand you,
and they're not really
going to talk back
except for maybe
asking for your brains.
So this could
explain how you get
these sorts of language fluency
problems in the CDHD disorder.
The final symptom I'm going to
go over for CDHD is movement.
And this is what really--
when you ask somebody
to pretend to be a zombie, the
first thing they do is move
and walk like a
zombie-- so let's
see a classic zombie
movement here.
I want you to pay
attention to how
these creatures are walking.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TIM VERSTYNEN: All right.
So we have arms out, wide
lumbering stiff stance.
They tend to do this, right?
So there's obviously
something wrong with the way
their brains are
coordinating their actions.
So let's take a quick look
at the general circuits
in the brain the
regulate our movements.
There are three big
collective circuits
in the brain that
drive our actions.
There's actually
many more than this.
These are just the
big sets of them.
In the neocortex.
You have the
cortical motor areas.
So this is our
zombie subject here.
This is their brain.
Everything shown here in gray
are cortical motor areas.
And this is actually
a collection
of a few dozen different
areas that collectively
coordinate your actions.
And they're
responsible for things
like sensory integration,
movement planning, and movement
execution.
So they kind of plan what to
do with the marionette strings
of your muscles and joints
and coordinate those movements
together.
Underneath the motor cortex
and deep in the brain
is an area known as
the basal ganglia.
This is the second
major motor pathway.
So this little alien-looking
creature in here, that's
a subcortical nuclei and part
of the basal ganglia circuit.
And what they do is they're
responsible for gating
or inhibiting actions.
So really they're the
gatekeepers of the movements
that you execute.
So they decide whether
or not you're actually
going to throw a brick
through a window or not.
So they kind of make that
final output decision.
And then in the back
of the head here--
this is shown right
back here-- is
a little cauliflower-shaped
area of the brain
known as the cerebellum.
Cerebellum's responsible
for motor timing
and actual temporal
perception, too,
coordination, and
error correction.
So it's the kind of quality
assessment guy that makes sure
that your actions are
being conducted smoothly
and without major errors.
So each one of these three areas
contributes in different ways
to different types
of motor control.
Now when most people look at
the way that zombies move,
the first thing
they'll say is, oh,
they look like they
have Parkinson's.
In fact, "Slate" just had a
write-up of one of our chapters
in the book yesterday.
And their first title, before
we got them to change it,
was "Do Zombies
have Parkinson's?"
And Parkinson's is a disorder
of the basal ganglia.
So patients with Parkinson's
lose a major pathway
in this system, and it results
in a very particular type
of movement disorders.
But let me show you what
Parkinson's patients look
like when they have
full-blown movement disorders.
So typically they'll
have slouched posture.
They're losing postural control.
Their hands are
closer to their sides.
And the way they walk are
short, shuffling steps.
This is a very characteristic
Parkinson's walk.
That's not what we see in
the CDHD disorder at all.
We see wide legs, stiff, arms
out as if balance problems,
and these kind of
lumbering walks.
That kind of movement actually
resembles a different motor
disorder known as
Spinocerebellar Ataxia.
So individuals with SCA,
or Spinocerebellar Ataxia,
suffer from an
inability to produce
smooth, coordinated actions.
And it results in these kind
of lumbering movements, balance
problems, tremors, slurred
speech, visual eye movement
problems.
So a host of different
movement problems.
And they all resolve
around the fact
that patients with this
disorder are suffering
from a degeneration of
the cerebellum itself.
So the cerebellum
atrophies away,
and it causes these
movement disorders.
In fact, if you want to know
just a very little bit what
it's like to suffer
from this disorder,
think about the last
time you were drunk.
You had balance problems,
your slurred speech,
your kind of stumbled walk.
Those are all
cerebellar symptoms,
because the alcohol's explicitly
influencing and affecting
the cerebellum.
So that's what these individuals
suffer on a daily basis
without the euphoria of alcohol.
So those kind of movements
are very, very characteristic
of cerebellar damage.
Now the cerebellum is probably
my favorite area of the brain.
It's that kind of
underappreciated
in the neuroscientific
community.
It contains half of the
neurons in the brain,
so even though the
neocortex is bigger,
the cerebellum contains
half of the neurons.
And it had a sordid history.
There were a ton of really
off-the-wall theories
about what the cerebellum did.
Early on, it was
thought to regulate
the fluids of the body.
There was once a theory that it
was the battery of the brain,
so it was just doing voltaic
battery generation in order
to produce electrical impulses.
But perhaps my favorite early
theory of the cerebellum
came from the phrenologists.
The phrenologists were
the early neuroscientists
who tried to map out
lumps on the head
with certain personality
characteristics.
And the phrenologists
thought that the cerebellum
is the root of the libido.
They thought that
all your sexual drive
came from the cerebellum.
And they were scientists.
I like to knock
the phrenologists,
but they practiced
the scientific method.
And they figured
this out because they
would go to French
prisons and then feel
bumps on the heads of
different criminals.
And they just noticed
that criminals
with chronic habitual
masturbation problems
had larger bumps over
the back of their head
by where the cerebellum was.
So they thought, ah, they've
got large cerebellum,
so that's what's driving
these sexual impulses.
And to their credit,
they actually
tried an experimental
manipulation
to see if they could
prove this theory.
So in one individual,
this poor female inmate,
they strapped an ice cube
to the back of her head,
strapped it in, tied it
in, a giant block of ice,
and noticed that this inmate
stopped touching herself
when the ice cube was strapped
to the back of her head.
So voila, they proved
that the cerebellum
is responsible for the libido.
So if you're like me,
you could probably
see many different
reasons why people
would stop touching themselves
with a giant block of ice
strapped to the
back of their head.
And another
individual who kind of
shared this theory was
this gentleman here,
Pierre Flourens.
Pierre Flourens was a
classic neuroanatomist
and neurophysiologist
who was really
a pioneer of early neurology.
And he thought this
was ridiculous.
So I'm going to read you
a quote from an article
about his discovery of how
the cerebellum is actually
linked to motor control.
"Flourens dismissed as
unfounded the claims
for the sexual function
of the cerebellum.
He removed the cerebellum
of a mature rooster.
The animal was still deeply
interested in the hens,
but motor dysfunction
made it difficult
for him to express his
feelings towards them."
I love that little
delicate ending there.
So basically the
rooster was still randy,
but he couldn't really
coordinate his actions
to make his affections known.
So this was actually
the first explicit case
showing that the cerebellum
was linked to motor control.
And it didn't happen
until the mid-1800s.
So since then, we've
done a lot of work
characterizing how
the cerebellum is
linked to motor control.
Now, cerebellum sits
right back here in humans.
And over here in
the zombie brain,
you see that the
cerebellum is pretty much
completely atrophied.
So these kinds of
movement disorders
that you see in zombies reflect
severe cerebellar dysfunction.
Now any zombie movie
fan in the audience
is going to be a little
bit frustrated this point,
because so far I've
only been talking
about one very particular
subtype of the CDHD disorder
known as the Slow
Zombie Subtype, right?
These are the
classic early forms
of the disease as we saw it.
But more recently
another subtype
has emerged, particularly
starting around 2000 to 2004,
and that's the Fast
Zombie Subtype, right?
These guys don't lumber.
They don't have
discoordinated actions.
They can climb.
They can-- if you've watched
the movie "World War Z,"
they can swarm.
And these are vicious,
vicious predators out there.
So we wanted to
say, OK, well, what
is the difference between
this guy and this guy?
So Brad and I could have
flew out to England,
grabbed ourselves a
set of fast zombies,
brought them back to the lab,
and looked at their brains.
And if you compare the
brains of the slow zombie
to the fast zombie, you see
some very interesting things.
First off, you see
that the fast zombie
has an intact cerebellum.
So they still have this motor
coordination ability intact.
They also have no atrophy in
the superior parietal portions
of the brain.
These are the brain
portions up here,
which means they have actually
better spatial attention
as well.
So there's not as
extensive brain damage
in the fast zombie as what
you see in the slow zombie
variant of the CDHD disorder.
So what drives this difference?
Why do we suddenly see
this different subtype
in the disease?
Well, again, we did
extensive research.
We watched a ton
of movies, and then
had to re-watch them
when we were sober.
The one thing we
noticed time and time
again was that in the
new fast zombie subtype,
the time between infection
and resurrection to zombie
became quite short.
So we developed what
we call now the Time
to Resurrection hypothesis.
So according this
hypothesis, the time
between sudden death due to
infection and resurrection,
if it's short, as you see in a
fast zombie, the amount of time
that the brain is starved
of oxygen and glucose
is relatively short.
So what happens when the
brain the starved of oxygen
and glucose, it
starts to die away.
It induces itself into this
hypoxic state and tissue
loss occurs.
So if that's
relatively short, you
don't get as extensive
of tissue loss.
But if-- as in
the older variant,
like we saw in
"The Living Dead,"
it would take hours, days,
weeks, or months in order
to resurrect-- that's
going to lead to much more
extensive damage,
because the brain
is starved of those
resources for much longer.
The cerebellum and
early visual areas
are particularly
sensitive to hypoxia.
So this would predict
that we should
see a negative correlation
between the walking
speed of an undead individual
and the time at which it
took them to resurrect.
So this could explain why we
get the two different subtypes
of the CDHD disorder.
All right.
So what might cause CDHD?
Well, there's lots of
potential pathogens
that could cause this disorder.
Viruses are known
to attack the brain.
What you're seeing
here is an individual
who had a neural infection
with the herpes simplex virus.
So everything you
see here in white
is calcified neural tissue.
This is the same
virus that gives you
cold sores in your mouth,
except every once in awhile,
instead of traveling
out a cranial nerve,
it travels up to the brain.
And it can cause extensive
damage up in, particularly,
the prefrontal cortex.
But most viral damages
we know to the brain
are very nonspecific
and just very global.
They wouldn't lead to
a very specific pattern
of global behavioral deficit.
So we don't think viruses
are what's causing the zombie
brain, much to the frustration
of the producers of "28 Days
Later."
Bacteria is another potential
source of the infection.
This is an image of
an individual who
had meningitis, which is
a bacterial infection.
And you see that meningitis
ate away basically the lower
quarter of this
individual's brain.
It's a massive
infectious disease.
And the damage that it does
is, again, very nonspecific.
So while viruses and bacteria
know to influence the brain,
they don't lead to these
coordinated, specific regional
changes in brain tissue.
Another potential
candidate is prions.
So prions are little
forms a protein
that can unfold the cellular
structure of, basically,
all cell types,
particularly neurons.
And so this is a brain
image of an individual
with Creutzfeldt-Jakob disease.
Everything in white, again,
is areas of calcified tissue
that have been damaged.
And again, prions
are nonspecific.
Now, I apologize if you
don't sleep tonight,
but another potential
candidate is brain worms.
Yes, brain worms are real.
This is a syndrome known
as neurocysticercosis.
And these arrows pointing
to these little sacks here,
can you guess what's
in the little sacks?
Yes.
A little tapeworm that
buries itself in the brain
and siphons off nutrients
from your blood supply.
And this happens from eating
fecal-contaminated foods.
And we actually
think it's probably
epidemic in third
world countries.
But normally these brain
worms don't do any harm.
They just take up a
little bit of space.
They siphon off a
little bit of resources.
But they don't cause
big behavioral problems,
until you have,
as I tell you now,
one patient had three
dozen worms in his head.
He started showing
behavioral symptoms,
but that was because
his head basically
turned into Swiss cheese.
So we can imagine a case where
maybe a subtype of these worms
is forming a chemical
interaction with the brain
and leading to these slow
specific behavioral changes.
Another hypothesis that was
put out in the literature is--
if anybody's seen the
movie "The Signal"--
that TV and radio transmissions
can emit a particular EM
frequency that causes the neuron
activity patterns to change
fundamentally.
And we know that you
can actually kill cells
by letting them just fire a lot.
So you can see coordinated
brain damage, which we sometimes
call excitotoxicity, induced
by particular stimulus inputs.
And again, this is the premise
for the movie "The Signal."
And I first thought that
was silly, until I saw this.
[MUSIC - RICK ASTLEY, "NEVER
GONNA GIVE YOU UP"]
So I don't know
about you, but that
makes me want to kill somebody.
So I'm going to go
with the Rick Astley
theory of the CDHD disorder.
All right.
So, so far I've
shown how you can
look at this silly pop
culture supernatural
entity, this little zombie
here, characterize it
in a very rigorous way, in
a scientific manner, where
we can link up specific
behavioral traits to the brain
and use real science to kind
of explain a relatively silly,
supernatural organism
like the zombie.
So this really
shows the potential
of trying to kind of
push this scientific idea
into popular culture
in order to educate
real scientific principles
and the general public.
So in a way, what
we're trying to do
is keep building this bridge
between popular culture
and science, and get these
to interplay more in order
to facilitate greater
scientific education.
So if you want to know more,
you can obviously read our book,
"Do Zombies Dream
of Undead Sheep?"
We also have a set of
animated videos released
through the Ted Ed Foundation.
They are great supporters
of science outreach.
I love the Ted Ed Foundation.
So we have two videos up about
how to diagnose the zombie
brain, and some fallacies
in using your imaging
to explain brain
behavior relationships.
We also have a
set of colleagues,
a collective in the
Zombie Research Society.
This is a bunch of
academics who use zombies
to teach their particular field.
Actually, two members of
the Zombie Research Society
are here in Boston
and Cambridge.
Dan Dresner teaches the
politics and political science
of zombies, and
he's over at Tufts.
And Steve Schlozman is at
MGH, and he's a psychiatrist,
and he does these
psychiatry of zombies.
And he actually published a
novel on the zombie disorder
as a psychiatric condition,
which is really fun.
So if you're not interested in
neuroscience, but other fields,
check out the people who are
associated with the Zombie
Research Society because
they do great work like this.
So thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about popular zombie movies
and TV shows, where you see
them as truly scientifically
inaccurate, either in general
or in specific important scenes.
TIM VERSTYNEN:
Actually, I would say
99% of the zombies
seen in TVs and movies
are so unrealistic as
to make them impossible.
There are a few exceptions.
There is a video game,
"The Last of Us,"
in which a evolution of
the cordyceps fungus, which
actually induces zombieism
in ants-- really, it does--
somehow mutates and causes the
same thing to happen in humans,
so you see these
zombies running around
with giant fungi
attached to their heads.
And that is one that
I thought was actually
a fairly realistic one, because
they're also not undead.
You could easily kill them.
And then the most
realistic representation
of zombies that I would say
had the biological plausibility
were the zombies in the "28
Days Later" and "28 Weeks Later"
movies.
And for those of you
who haven't seen it,
the premise of the movie is
that scientists in Oxford
are trying to understand rage,
and they develop a virus known
as the rage virus, which
plays with the aggression
circuits in the brain.
And it gets loose in the
general public, and what happens
is people just become really
just ravenously aggressive.
They're not undead.
In fact, the premise is that 28
days later means that they're
not thinking about
eating, so they're
going to starve to
death in 28 days.
And so you can ideally wait
out the zombie apocalypse
just by letting them
starve to death.
So I thought that
probably "28 Days Later"
was the most biologically
plausible one.
But even then the behavioral
patterns and the transmission
rates were nowhere
near plausible.
The scene that
frustrated me the most
was the last-- at the
end of "The Walking Dead"
first season, when
they were in the CDC
and there was this biologically
plausible explanation
of the neuroscience of zombies.
Was so bad that it made me cry.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of realistic zombies,
there's this notion
of the voodoo zombies
and being controlled by
drugs on mutations and stuff.
I'm just curious how
that plays into--
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
So that's actually another
little side tangent of mine,
because the zombieism that you
see in Haitian voodoo culture
is quite interesting
in that it has
a proposed neuropharmacological
explanation.
So there's a classic
book by Wade Davis, who
was an ethnobotanist,
who went down to Haiti
and made two particular
pharmacological links
to Haitian zombieism.
One was tetrodotoxin,
which was the poison used
to simulate death.
And tetrodotoxin works by
blocking the sodium channels
that allow neurons to fire in
the peripheral nervous system.
So your muscles
become paralyzed.
And it actually won't kill
you unless your diaphragm
stops working.
So basically it kills you
because the diaphragm muscle
stops working.
But if you get a low
enough dose, what'll happen
is that your diaphragm will
keep moving so slowly that you
can't really detect it.
But in all intents and
purposes you look dead.
So that's the simulated death.
And then the control
aspects, he proposed
that the bokors, who are kind of
the bad or evil voodoo priests,
would dose the individual after
the tetrodotoxin had worn off--
when they dug them
out of their grave
that they were buried alive in--
would douse them with Datura,
which has three
major psychoactive
ingredients, hyoscopine,
scopalamine, and atropine,
I think.
Each one of those will
induce a psychotic state.
And so the idea is that you
can make this person who is now
convinced that he's dead--
because he saw himself dead,
he was well aware of everything
that was happening to him,
felt buried-- and
then he gets raised
and then there's a
psychoactive chemical
that keeps him compliant.
That was the Wade Davis theory.
It's controversial, hasn't
been replicated yet.
And people are saying that
there's probably other aspects
to it that link more to
psychological belief.
But yeah, the
Haitian voodoo zombie
kind of links to neurobiology,
quite interesting that way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
So one was what
causes zombieism.
So in some forms of movies, it's
kind of like a venomous thing,
that if you're bitten, you're
infected, and you get it.
In other more recent
ones, it's everyone's
infected, when you
die, you're a zombie.
They're really
different outcomes.
I don't know if you had any
thoughts about that difference.
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah, I--
the, we're all infected
and we're just going to
reanimate when we're-- you
know, whenever we kind of
transition from one state.
Romero was-- so we actually
got to interview George Romero
and we were asking him about it.
And he said the way he made it,
particularly in his first three
movies, he didn't care about it.
He was trying to use the
zombies as a metaphor.
So in the first one, he
kept it vague, right?
There was the satellite from
outer space that had come back,
and it was somehow
linked to that.
But it could've been
space radiation.
And he was saying
he explicitly didn't
care about what caused it.
He just wanted them to be there.
In fact, he put the nail
in our coffin of our theory
about zombie movement.
Them.
But I'll tell you
about that later.
So I think what happened
was because the early zombie
cultures didn't really
care about the mechanism,
there were just lots of
different explanations.
From a biological
standpoint it doesn't
seem like that
would be the case.
There is one-- so
I like the idea
of the infection
theory of zombieism.
AUDIENCE: Like [? latents. ?]
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
The real phenomenon that I think
fascinates me the most in this
is toxoplasmosis.
So toxoplasmosis is a
single-cell organism.
It's what lives in cat poop.
And it's why pregnant
women shouldn't
be around cat poop
is because it induces
flu-like symptoms if
you get the infection.
And it can be dangerous to
fetuses and young children.
But normally, if you're
an adult and you get it,
you just get a flu and
it seems to go away.
But really what happens is it's
a single-cell organism that
reproduces sexually in the
gut of a feline, right,
so that's where it gets
its most genetic diversity.
When it's outside the feline,
it can only reproduce asexually,
so it clones itself.
So what this organism does
is, even after the infection,
it stays latent in your system.
And in the mammals that it
infects-- rodents, humans--
it actually starts modifying
the neuropharmacology
of the individual's brain.
And what you see is, you see
characteristic behavioral
differences in people who have
had toxoplasmosis and survive
versus those who don't.
And the most
classic case of this
was an experimental
study where they
took a rat-- and rats
normally hate cats,
they're instinctively
afraid of cats-- gave it
a toxoplasmosis intervention,
and across time,
if you had a glass wall
between the rat and the cat,
normally the rat's over here.
But as the infection
rate occurs,
the rat actually
starts to not only
not be afraid, but want
to be near the cat.
So there's increased
risk-taking behavior
that happens as a
result of the infection.
And actually, that same
kind of behavior-- not
towards cats, obviously, but
more risk-taking behavior
is seen in human individuals
who've had the infection.
So somehow, the
single-cell organism
is hijacking the
complex circuits
that induce our ability to
be afraid of certain things
and increase risk taking.
So that, coupled with the
kind of popularization
of the infection
theory of zombies,
I think, is the more
interesting link there.
And if you were going to ask
me about biologically possible,
with the caveat that it's still
way, way far away, that, I
think, is more the route
that you would see something
like this.
AUDIENCE: This is
more than the rat
simply becoming
acclimated to having
a cat on the other
side of a glass wall.
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
So you don't see
it all in rats that
have never been
exposed to the virus.
They stay far away.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Another question
I had for you, quickly.
So you talked about the amygdala
and rage and anger, aggression.
There's also-- I've heard of
Kluver-Bucy syndrome, which
is behind controlled appetite.
You didn't talk much about
why the appetite side of rage
can be all sorts of
aggressive behavior.
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
So Kluver-Bucy syndrome is
a rare neurological disorder
that happens-- it
can only occur when
you get both amygdala damaged.
And they exhibit
hyperorality, hypersexuality,
and it's a very odd
characteristic feature.
So you caught a
hole in our theory,
because according to
our theory, zombies
should be hyperoral,
hypersexual.
They should also
be hyperfearful,
because the amygdala actually
controls fight and flight.
So what it's doing is,
if you leave it intact,
zombies should be just as
easily spooked as pissed off.
So you did catch the
hole in the theory.
Right, right, right.
All right.
Any more questions?
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So there was this
CDC blog post awhile ago about
what to do in the event
of a zombie outbreak.
Do you have any
critiques of that?
Did they do a good job?
TIM VERSTYNEN: I loved that.
I thought they did a
great job, because really,
what they were doing is epidemic
preparedness and emergency
preparedness, but just
couched in zombies.
I mean, it got
people's attention.
It got people excited
about doing it.
Instead of just
doing, OK, we're going
to pretend that there's
a SARS virus out.
People kind of habituate
to these things.
But if you do it tongue in
cheek, people got engaged,
and it got a lot
of-- I think it got
a lot more people
interested and thinking
about preparedness for
epidemics and emergencies
than if they had just
done anything else,
except for maybe now they could
probably do it with ebola.
But otherwise, yeah, I
thought it was a great idea.
And I like seeing agencies
do that tongue-in-cheekness
to kind of engage
awareness and attention.
Did you still have
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just real quick, First
of all, thank you.
Super helpful.
I added more cardio into my life
after I watched "Zombieland,"
so I'm more prepared.
The second was, do you and your
friends at The Zombie Research
Society plan on doing research
into other parts of the zombie
body, so beyond the brain?
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah,
so we did a Reddit AMA.
And one of the questions
was about the gut system.
And I think the next
avenue of zombie science
is zombie internal medicine.
Because how do zombies
get their nutrients
when you've got your entrails
dragging on the ground?
I think that's a
fascinating question.
So I think that getting
people interested in talking
about digestive systems
and poop is normally not
that interesting, but couched in
zombies, it can be interesting.
Same with, I think, cardiac
systems and blood systems
from a biological angle.
I think there's lots
on the biological side
that you could explore
on the zombie body,
because their physiology-- how
do you explain how you could
have somebody that's got thick,
viscous blood, but somehow
still manages to be animated?
So yeah, I think
that would be a fun
avenue on the biological side.
And of course, on
the social side,
you can use zombies to
explain anything, right?
Different hierarchical
societies, zombie cognitive
phenomenon, I think, would
be really interesting.
So I don't really
think there's anything
you can't do with zombies just
because they keep changing.
They're not like
vampires or werewolves,
which have a very
static structure.
Zombies keep changing with
time, so you can always
find an example of a
zombie doing something
that you want to study.
But yeah, I'm waiting for
the zombie internal medicine.
AUDIENCE: So one connection
that you didn't touch on
is between rabies and zombieism.
I've heard people
talk about that.
Any comments on whether rabies
would be, or a form of rabies
would be [INAUDIBLE]?
TIM VERSTYNEN: So
the longer version
of the talk we actually
go over this, because when
we go over the memory systems
and the impulse control
systems, those are all linked up
to a system known as the Papez
circuit.
That's a classic
neurological circuit
that was discovered
in the 1930s.
It was discovered
using the rabies virus.
And so what this guy,
James Papez would do is,
he was trying to find a link
between emotion and intention.
How is it that we can't remember
what we did at the store
yesterday, but
everybody remembers
where they were at 9/11, right?
How do we have these emotional
bondings of memories?
And so he mapped out
this theoretical circuit,
and then would map it out in
cats by injecting the rabies
virus and watching the
virus propagate from one
area to the next, look
for the connections.
And he actually made cats
that had memory problems,
they were hyperaggressive.
So we do a tongue-in-cheek
thing saying
that James Papez made
the first zombie cats.
But the rabies virus is a very
specific type of infection,
and it's very general.
So what it does is, it kind
of attacks a particular cell,
jumps across what's
under the synapse, which
is the gap between
cells, and keeps
propagating down
to the next cell.
And it just wanders.
It just kind of follows
from place to place.
So if you get an infection in
one part of the brain, where
it goes is determined by
who it's connected with.
And it'll keep traveling
until it basically
kills the organism.
Now normally you
get some symptoms
like cognitive disorders.
You'll get delusions and
dementia with rabies infection.
You get hydraphobia,
so individuals
infected with rabies virus
will be afraid of water.
They won't drink.
They become dehydrated.
And some of those are
explained by the virus
doesn't survive well when
there's lots of brain swelling,
so it automatically
dehydrates you
to keep that brain
swelling down.
Things like that
have been put forth
as explanations for
those kind of behaviors.
But I think a lot
of them just happen
to be, people show those
when the virus has spread
so far throughout the brain
as to basically wipe away
most of the neocortex.
And so it's nonspecific in the
sense of where it's attacking,
but we really start to see
the symptoms once it's just
so widespread as
to be catastrophic.
So yeah, the rabies
virus has been
linked to zombies more times
than, I think, anything else.
So the book "World War Z,"
the first name for the virus
was African Rabies
because they first
talked about it in South Africa.
And there's been a lot of
movies that talk tongue-in-cheek
about a rabies-like infection.
So I think that's
just because more
of the kind of hyperaggressive
impulsive responses.
But we don't really see
how that's occurring yet
until you get to this
catastrophic stage.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TIM VERSTYNEN: Yeah.
Right.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah.
So that's a good kind of
infectious disease that way,
to use the metaphor.
Yeah.
All right?
Any other questions?
Thank you guys very much.
Thanks for inviting me out.
Happy Halloween.